hi i'm sydney park and i play makani
young hi i'm asia cooper and i play alex
hi i'm dale whibley and i play zack
sanford hey my name is jesse la turret
and i play darby hi my name is diego
joseph and i play roderico and we are
the cast of there's someone inside your
house here with buzzfeed to see if we
will survive the end of a slasher movie
here we go
first things first which horror
stereotype are you
are the answers the scream queen
the jock
the nerd who explains everything
the skeptic
oh the final girl or the killer
i feel like i definitely know who asia
is
damn
i think i'm the final girl i knew you
were going to say that
i could see that i'm a skeptic
oh dude i was literally gonna say the
same thing yeah
actually not gonna lie blonde hair you
know what i'd probably be the jock
no
but it's who you personally would be
who i would be the skeptic for sure i
would not believe any of this is going
on i'd be like this is [ __ ] like i
want to be the final girl but i am a
screenplay
yes
yes
i want to be the final girl i went with
the skeptic i had to because that's 100
me pick a hero to join your friend group
sydney from scream
chris from get out
laurie from halloween
richie from it
danny from midsummer
and jessica from parasite oh
i'm gonna join neither richie or jessica
um
it took him a minute to figure out what
was going on
yo no i'm gonna go with laurie laurie's
got like all right
he's got the like the hideout underneath
her kitchen he's good
yeah jamie like wait you're saying in
real life or in a horror movie who would
you want on your side lori lori in real
life okay like justin get out and made
it he made
because of his friend chris it took him
like two and a half hours to figure it
out i knew immediately
like it took him too long
it took him way too long to figure out
that those people were crazy okay we get
it well you're right
i'm going with lauren yeah lord yeah
that's a good choice y'all i'm glad
you're leaving me behind
leave me back richie's just jokes so i
feel like he'd be a good friend
i'm going with jessica from here instead
you hear a mysterious noise outside your
house what do you do
first option is lock the doors and
windows
the go outside and see what's out there
call
hide in the 911
not a damn thing it ain't none of my
business
jokes on you i'm not even home
lock the doors and windows i might just
grab a knife that's yes
knock the doors and windows and then
grab a knife as well because i feel like
sometimes you call 9-1-1 and they're
like yeah it's always out here there's
nobody out here yeah
yeah i feel like
a little
for a noise bang it's just a noise no
calling 9-1-1 hello this is a white
woman please come
wasn't it in scream drew barrymore
locked the doors and windows and she
still got that
yeah cause he was in there i feel
[Laughter]
focused on you i'm not even home there
we go i'm gonna go with that one yeah
yeah i think that's gonna be right
i'll join that train i did the not a
damn thing it ain't none of my business
now pick the horror villain making the
noise
oh candy man from candyman
annabelle from annabelle jack from the
shining no thanks freddy krueger from
the nightmare on elm street
pennywise from it
you go space from screen we can take
ghost faces okay so it's who you want to
fight all them other crazies i don't
know yeah
i couldn't take any of them yeah i feel
like maybe annabelle
annabelle
annabelle's paranormal though yeah
yeah i'm thinking ghost face because you
can take off his mask
plus he's in a robe so he'll trip on
that nose coming at you like you're not
going to be like there's an actual human
behind there like what's behind that
thing yeah it looks like a mask i would
like to see a human coming at me if that
would be i'm with you jesse
i nominate dale to go after him and then
we'll tag
girl's face i'm doing it i love him jack
he does seem like the easiest to play
oh no the sound is now coming from
inside your house
defend yourself
a lamp
a kitchen knife golf clubs which don't
work
a hydro flask
flower vase
a weapon i'm hiding in the closet now
why would someone get a hydroglass yeah
a hydroplasty oh i guess your bees like
okay so wait why do golf clubs not work
because they didn't work in the movie
you don't remember but you could do some
damage with a goal do some damage but
man you just have to be super strong
yeah i feel like i'll do more damage to
myself with the kitchen knife though so
i'm going to either go with the light
you want the right golf club you want to
keep them away from
i'm doing the golf club because you can
keep them at a distance yeah guys what
i'm doing the kitchen i feel like the
gold clubs are fun i'm nice because one
whack to the shin or like to the neck
you know like
yeah yeah yeah yeah
think about that you could do like they
do in the movies with like pool cues you
can snap it in half and you got two
little sharp custard tubes
looking like a golf club to the throat i
only fear is them catching it then i'm
screwed because i don't know what to do
we got 12. 12 more
did i say clubs plural it did yeah yeah
wait maybe maybe i chose the wrong thing
yeah you said i'm glam i chose the vods
oh we're fancy for buzzfeed so you
managed to find a hiding spot all right
but you could only grab one thing
your cell phone to call for help your
car keys in case you get a chance to
escape your pet where they go you go
oh man it's gonna be me a flashlight in
case the power gets shut off a snack you
may get hungry and this could take a
while
nothing i've been in the closet this
whole time not this person not leaving
carnegie's i'm gonna go with my pet for
sure chicken can't be left behind
i love my pet but kibbles kibbles no she
would okay but is is okay so we all went
with ghost face right
does ghost face kill animals
probably just people right he's just a
people killer evil i feel like he would
kill an animal if he had to
just put them in the closet a chicken
she makes noise my cat named chicken
chicken she makes noise she's a princess
and that's my daughter i can't leave
behind my daughter i feel like in a
horror movie how are you making me feel
guilty for taking the car
yeah yeah
loki's looking at me right now what did
you just say right yeah
like he's like what are you saying i
think i'm going to go with martin
yeah car keys the only thing is jesse do
we have gas i always
perform
honestly you only got to get down the
road you got to get to this and start
filling up yeah i'll go
do the same for you damn the killer
found you what's your final move join
them
find them
run to a different hiding place scream
join them distract them so that others
can escape
surrender if it's all of us i'm gonna
just fight them wait if it's all of us
then shouldn't we fight them
i could distract we can take those
phases okay we'll split up we'll split
up two of us distract that three of us
fight all right i'm gonna go with the
[ __ ]
i'm gonna go with fighting
i'm gonna go with fight two because i
have a knife go back scale you distract
yeah we got the clubs but we'll we'll
take it
you guys take the ball
they'll distract
asia in the back like a pokemon trainer
hey sydney go
all right i'll fight them who's joining
them right
my minions like what
but i guess i'll fight
okay i survived you guys and guess what
the gift is it's sydney it's neve
campbell okay from scream so
mental beat meant to be and chicken
surviving with me
i don't understand how you survived you
played a game oh guys i hate the game i
made it i hate that i like it
mine says congrats you survived you made
it one of us
tale i would die in a slasher movie
oh no
i would die the killer got me before i
got them i tried to fight and i lost so
that's because i went to distract i'm
sorry your life's true no i went to
fight i i'm fine you guys got away i
died you guys got away stop free
well actually i died too but i didn't
die first it says you died but you
didn't die first i'm confused
i was making all the right decisions
yeah maybe
i think that's why because i got that
too i made all the right decisions i
died but i didn't die first
so that gave me that gave me hope and
god was like or it was your daughter
though
or it was the boss
thank you so much buzzfeed make sure to
tune into our movie there's someone
inside your house now streaming on
netflix
[Music]
you